as soon as robert mueller was appointed
special counsel in the russia
investigation
politicians rushed to cover him with a
blanket of invincibility
senator tillis have you seen anything in
this investigation so far that would
suggest that robert mueller has a
conflict
no i haven't i sit on the judiciary
committee along with
chris or senator coons and i have not
seen any evidence to suggest that
i do not at all believe that
that mr muller's has been compromised or
his investigation
i think he's beyond reproach i have a
lot of admiration and respect for
director mueller
you've got somebody who by all accounts
is an independent
person somebody who's got lots of
integrity he enjoys very broad support
in the senate both among republicans and
democrats because of his long service as
the fbi director
because of his record of respectable
leadership as a senior federal
prosecutor
well in other words president trump
don't you
dare even think about coming close
even sort of maybe kind of firing
mueller
well a few months later congress rushed
in to propose legislation
to insulate the special counsel from
executive branch
interference or termination republican
pro amnesty center tom tillis
along with liberal delaware senator
chris coons introduced a bill
that would allow mueller to challenge
any removal
in court now senator lindsey graham
and cory booker wonder twin powers
activate
they went even further they sponsored a
bill that would prevent
the firing of mueller apparently he's so
perfect he can never be fired
well senators ted cruz and mike lee were
properly skeptical about the
constitutionality of
any such moves such as that remember
mueller works for the executive branch
after all
so i have a question why can't all
federal employees challenge their firing
well of course this would be absurd now
setting aside whether it would be
politically smart for president trump to
fire mueller and it wouldn't be smart
he is the head of the executive branch
and congress has
no business interfering with either the
firing
or the hiring decisions of the executive
branch all they have is the confirmation
process for senate confirmation
otherwise stay out of the business so my
question is
why were these senators so eager to
build up mueller and his team
and they were so eager to insulate them
from executive branch
oversight and ultimately perhaps
termination
well thank god we have diligent
congressmen who do take their oversight
responsibility
seriously i'm talking about congressman
devin nunes matt
gates trey gowdy robert goodlatte and
peter king who will join us in just a
few moments you don't want to miss this
segment
their determination to see that this
investigation doesn't turn into some
kind of star chamber
i mean it's already turned up incredible
things so far
missing or discussed thumb drives talk
of deleting text messages
talk of creating insurance policies
against trump
maybe even secret societies in the fbi
meetings convened outside of the fbi and
of course
all those missing texts that they may or
may not be reconstructing
and by the way speaking of these texts
between peter strzok and his gal pal
lisa page
we heard this today from the doj
spokeswoman
there were just over 50 000 text
messages
between lisa page and peter strzok
during the time period that the
inspector general is investigating
and what we also know is that for about
a five month period
those text messages never got into the
fbi server
obviously we are reviewing immediately
how they didn't get into the server in
the first place
first of all who has anything that much
to say to anyone that would account for
50 000 texts i mean they must have
really had a hop-in relationship
um there were reports by the way that
that glitch that she referenced
may have affected 35 000
fbi employees and all their cell phones
different from what we heard a few days
ago
but whatever the case it prompts more
questions now
just about the basic competency of the
fbi
oh sorry or are we not even allowed to
wonder
what else peter strzok and lisa page
said to each other about
trump flynn comey and maybe
even the old hillary email investigation
i'm sure it wasn't all 50
000 texts of sweet nothings well by the
way i've noticed a pattern here
maybe you have as well the more we learn
and the closer congress gets to the
truth some of this
underlying evidence the more vicious the
media
attacks on those people who are seeking
answers
meetings off-site secret society
anything you can tell me
without you kill this is nonsense it's
just complete nonsense
you're telling me that that law
enforcement agency is treating people
unequally
because they have a political vendetta
if you're going to tell the american
people that that's what happens in third
world dictatorships that doesn't happen
here
republicans are talking about this
secret society
inside the fbi they sound like crackpots
they are going to rule the day of going
down this road and having this
institution
come apart and sully didn't have the
kind of morale problems
that could be long lasting down the road
and then who they're going to look to
well certainly not to the head of the
rnc who's trashing the current president
of the united states
well i'm just glad the democrats are
finally
finally supporting law enforcement the
fbi you can never question them
let's look back now for years the left
has indulged groups like
black lives matter the aclu and
care who reflexively impugn the
integrity
and character of police anytime
somebody captures one of those unplanned
pleasant cell phone videos
the police are too aggressive they're
racist they're anti-muslim you know the
drill
but now that mueller of course is state
versus federal but mueller is targeting
trump
oh boy law enforcement you can't
question them they can't do any wrong
they should never be fired hell they
shouldn't even be questioned
now one would think that the media some
in the media
would have a little bit of curiosity
about
i don't know the conflicts of interest
in the special counsel's office
if they distrust law enforcement and
investigators
on the state level so often why do the
feds get a pass
well there is without a doubt a
deep-seated animus and that's putting it
mildly
toward the president by key members of
the mueller investigative team
and rather than confront the growing
evidence
the left well they pull a saul lelinski
and they start demonizing members of
congress
and anyone frankly anyone who dares to
question the methods
and the motives of the obama justice
department and now the mueller gang
the black cloud that hangs over this
russian investigation
let me tell you this it wasn't created
by fox news
certainly wasn't created by talk radio i
mean none of us hired jeannie rhee who
previously worked for the clinton
foundation and represented obama's
national security advisor ben
rhodes i'll tell you this fox news and
talk radio did not appoint andrew
weissman as lead prosecutor
a democratic donor remember who he
praised sally yates in that letter when
she was fired by the president
and i don't think fox news and talk
radio appointed peter strzok either
i'll tell you this no amount of
scapegoating
is going to make this any better now
robert mueller could be the greatest guy
the smartest guy
ever but if the man cannot oversee his
own team
and remove the partisans then you have
to conclude
he's either in over his head or he's
just not good for this role or he's
negligent in this duty
and that will compromise the ultimate
findings of this investigation whatever
they may be
now i also want to say this trump's team
made some mistakes early on
i do not think and i've said this before
it was smart to fire
jim comey when they did
and it wasn't wise to talk to lester
holt about the decision
to fire jim comey and if the story is
true
well i probably would not have asked
acting fbi director mccabe
how he voted in the election i wouldn't
have done that either
the president has to be extra mindful
given the fact that he had
already ticked off the intel community
with his promise of reforms and of
course some of his criticisms
so you kick that deep state hornet's
nest and
you're liable to get stung really bad
well today the president told reporters
hey
i'm happy to talk to mueller are you
going to talk to mullen
i'm looking forward to it actually you
want to you have a date
just like you said there's been no
collusion whatsoever
there's no obstruction whatsoever and
i'm looking forward to it i would love
to do that and i'd like to do it as soon
as possible
listen i would do it well
i was listening to that audio he sure
seems like he has nothing to hide
and the president appears ready and
willing to be held up to scrutiny by the
mueller team he wants to clear his name
but what about the men and women who are
doing the scrutinizing
who's going to hold them accountable
no one should be above the law not the
president
not hillary clinton and not the special
counsel's team
and that's the angle